ici on n'a pas le choix on doit tout
arraché ou presque la moitié des murs
les planchers au complet le bas de la
cuisine on récupère ce qu'on est capable
de récupérer mais y'a pas grand chose à
récupérer
l'ampleur des dégâts surprend les
habitués des crues printanières de la
rivière chaudière ce qu'ils vivent c'est
du jamais vu
j'ai tout vécu 2006 2014 2017
j'ai jamais jamais jamais eu une goutte
sur le plancher jamais qu'il eut reconnu
au comptoir de cuisine mais les
beaucerons se retrousse les manches plus
de 250 personnes et des entreprises
établies dans la région vient de prêter
main forte aux sinistrés
bénévolat en général c'est comme ça d'un
bon oeil le jeu et là je vois comment
les arbres sont déracinés je vois aller
les laspales prépare à celle là c'est
vraiment incroyable c'est un et comment
ces désastres
je trouve que c'est vraiment que si sa
mère est arrivée je sais pas ce que
j'aurais fait que c'est vraiment
important disait d'aider les personnes
c'est carrément catastrophique
josé pour les gens ils se retrouvent
démunis sauf que même si on jette tout
pour mieux recommencer certaines maisons
seront condamnés au centre-ville des
immeubles appartements comme celui ci le
solage hydrofuge est complètement sorti
de terre dizaine de résidences qui est
présentement aussi que c'est fini pour
le les hisseront pure et utilisables ces
maisons seront rachetés par le
gouvernement et les terrains transformer
vos parties de chanterelles qui va
devenir un grand parc malheureusement en
attendant valérie p tit ne sait pas quoi
faire avec ses locataires une famille de
six qui doit désormais vivre dans une
tente roulotte même mis la casa j'ai pas
de réponse alors donné je sais pas j'en
ai pour un mois et plus de travaux
valérie pelletier se croisent les doigts
elle attend le dit le passage des
fonctionnaires du ministère de la
sécurité publique
ils seront en ville pour déterminer ce
et l'aura de l'aide du gouvernement
si pierre alexandre bolduc radio-canada
sainte marie